kendall that is great all right it is
time to get spooky in the kitchen
smith's chef jeff jackson i was gonna
get that right share
some fun halloween appetizers and treats
let's check it out
hello everyone i'm chef jeff from smith
and it's halloween one of my favorite
times of the year
for the treats and the goodies but most
of all i get to play with my food and
that's what we're going to do today i'm
going to show you some fun appetizers
that you can make that are super easy
super spooky
and super fun everybody can get involved
let me just show you let's get right
into it
okay so this first one i'm gonna do are
pumpkin uh
deviled eggs deviled eggs is perfect for
halloween just because of their name but
to make them pumpkin deviled eggs just
make a regular uh deviled egg recipe you
have
and to make them pumpkin we're gonna
cover them with paprika
to give them that orange color and then
what you do
is you get chives and cut them into
those pieces and that will be the little
pumpkin stem
that one's kind of fun and super easy
everybody will love those
okay next is one of my favorite this is
uh halloween shaped
pizza bagel pizza um super easy so you
just grab regular plain bagels
at your local smiths just over in the
bakery area or bread area
and then you take some just jarred pizza
sauce
throw on there like so
and then here's where the foam part
comes well actually let's get pepperoni
on there
um i like pepperoni just to cover up
that hole that you have in the
in the bagel so everything doesn't fall
through so that kind of covers it up
okay but the fun part is
is you in your local smith's deli you
can have them
slice for you mozzarella cheese and then
what you do is you get like a
halloween cookie cutters and we'll go a
pumpkin this time
and just cut that mozzarella out into
the halloween shape like this
and put it on there and then you can
decorate these are roasted red
bell peppers that i have that i've cut
into triangles and you can make the eyes
and the nose and the mouth but i had a
as you can see i've got a skeleton one
that i had and all these uh
speaking of which these cookie cutters i
also found at the in the promotional
aisle at the
local smiths okay and then you just
throw those in the oven and bake those
up
people will love those super easy okay
the next one is cookies
all right so this one is dracula
dentures so you take any cookie you like
any kind of
at all these are pumpkin or not pumpkin
these are oatmeal chocolate chip
and this is frosting that i found in
tubes you can find in the baking aisle
and it's red and then i'm gonna go ahead
and throw some
make these in the teeth really quickly
so you have your teeth
and then you put that on there so it
looks like a like a dracula mouth
and then you get these sliver almonds
and then they become the fangs
isn't that fun that's super cool okay
last but not least i've got a
chicken enchilada dip that i made that
has cream cheese
and uh green chilies enchilada sauce
we're gonna turn into a graveyard i went
ahead and i made chips out of uh
out of tortilla i went ahead and used
the cookie cutter of a tombstone
and we're just going to stick that in
there like this and then i've got
lettuce for the grass
and there's our graveyard chicken
enchilada dip so these are just all
really fun things that you can do and
you can find all these
ingredients your local smiths happy
halloween have fun with your food
we'll see you next time bye-bye those
are great that's fine all right for more
visit smithfoodanddrug.com and we will
be right back here on las vegas